[Music]
new at a loving to a disturbing trend in
las vegas the number of
murders is on the rise and the newest
statistic from metro police
show that domestic violence is the
number one cause so far this year
arko manna explains what's being done to
address the issue in this special report
orko well denise some experts say
there's been a rise in domestic violence
because more people are stuck at home
during the pandemic but the reality is
this is an issue that's been growing
over time
survivors say more early intervention is
needed and a local organization tells us
that's what they plan to do i thought it
was going to be
a good relationship for courtney dillon
what was supposed to be a love story in
2017
took a terrifying turn three months into
it i
was physically hit and it only got worse
from there
her partner at the time abused her for
more than two years
i got a screwdriver thrown at my head
and
it started to bleed he stepped on my
hands very hard
stopped me with a fork on my back
and also on my hand because i was trying
to block it courtney tells me there were
times she did not think
she would make it you're telling
yourself you're going to die
you're going to you're not going to live
anymore the latest numbers from metro
police show there have been 68 homicides
in las vegas through july 9th of 2021
in comparison there were 40 homicides
through that same time
last year that's a 70 percent increase
and the top factor leading to murders in
las vegas through july 9th of this year
is domestic violence at 12 homicides
this is real like this might be my last
moment when rachel haig was in high
school her boyfriend's verbal abuse
quickly turned physical and she feared
for her life
he ended up going backwards on the
freeway head-on in traffic
and was like this is all your fault like
we're both going to die right now
rachel tells me what could have helped
is if there were more upfront resources
including in schools about domestic
violence maybe in the moment when they
are experiencing those things
things will click a little bit a little
bit quicker that kind of proactive
action is exactly what the shade tree is
trying to take the domestic violence
shelter provides housing and case
management for survivors
but now they're working on direct
outreach at local casinos businesses and
organizations
to get ahead of the issue whether we put
a booth up or you ask us to come speak
because awareness for us is very
important and it's key to bringing the
issue to life
they hope to start by this october and
survivors say that's a great idea
if someone would have came to talk to us
just all as a group saying like
you can come here you can have someone
to talk to it would have been
such a relief courtney is in a much
better place now but her healing
continues
i feel like i'm getting myself back but
i'm not totally
there yet now metro police tell us that
they are also working with organizations
to try to stop this issue before these
domestic situations
escalate to those in need there are some
resources for you can call
the national domestic violence hotline
at 1-800-799-7233
and the shade tree also has a 24 7
crisis line
at 1-855-385-0072
reporting live tonight orco mana 8 news
now